he has his fake profile that every day I
have an alarm to tell him to shut the
[__] up
do any of you guys recognize this man
right here
that's the guy from stranger things yeah
the stranger that does look like you
yeah it is the guy the guy that was
having sex with all the moms and uh
that's a pool yeah Dr Montgomery yeah
Billy
spoiler bruh spoiler alert it's a good
show it comes back to life does he no oh
I didn't watch the recent stranger the
third one was don't spoil it so uh
there's a there's a thing that's
happened recently with this dude what do
you think it is Nick I think I heard
about this he started [__] moms in
real life
let's go into the thing that Joe said
what's the thing Joe said he started
[__] moms in real life I mean he
probably does probably I'm sure he does
a little bit true books tons of moms but
everybody like my age are pretty much
like Mom's age now anyway so it wouldn't
be that weird do you think actors
actors are those type of roles that they
play maybe I think a little bit maybe
some of them maybe after their job
they've become that if you if they're
really good I don't think they are if
they're methods because they're just not
good at acting yeah right if they're
really good that's like Angelina Jolie
um yeah they just became that after they
they lived it she does look like a
badass all the time though so I would
assume that once the camera stops
rolling she's probably not like super
soft and since she's probably still a
badass looks like she doesn't smile much
yeah just cuz but she has like Liam
Neeson probably is always losing his
family like
always taking calls it seems consistent
I think Heath Ledger turned into Joker
too much and then it was too much yeah
yeah it was Tuesday too much in his head
well luckily what happened with Dr
Montgomery isn't really uh it doesn't
have anything really to do with actual
him at all there was a person out there
who actually believed they were talking
to him
why they got catfished they got catfish
catfishing is strong bro but in a way
that's so surprising to me I think like
no matter what you do there's someone
that's willing to fall for a catfish
dupe like oh yeah as Extreme as you make
it yeah somebody is out there that can
fall for it and this is one of those
examples this girl believes she's a huge
fan of stranger things huge fan of Dr
Montgomery somehow she believed she was
speaking to the real Dr Montgomery
to the point where um Decker Montgomery
you know was was trying to uh convince
her to leave her husband and she did she
divorced her husband for Dr Montgomery
and then she believed that she was
dating Dr Montgomery all online who
Derek Montgomery is dating somebody like
another famous person but this fake you
gotta keep it secret dude yeah he was
saying that he's really in love with her
I'm really in love with you yeah but
online though online just online I never
saw him face to face nothing and he's
saying that like oh uh don't tell anyone
because I'm still technically dating
live and I don't want the public to find
out that I I love you give you the
inside scoop yeah so then he goes on to
this catfish and then you see the lady
she's like 58 and yeah pretty right yeah
yeah oh no sad and lonely and yeah you
can picture it so one of the things
where
um I guess one of the pieces of evidence
on how he was able to convince her is
still a little bit like how did he do
this because he tells her to tune in
like uh stranger things season four he's
like oh tune in on tonight's episode
specifically tells her that episode that
gets released yeah and uh DACA
Montgomery makes a return appearance on
that episode but nobody knew that yeah
whoa but he did yeah I guess do you
think maybe it was just a coincidence
because he's a dead character in the
series but he does come back for one
thing as a not at you could probably
look it up on IMDb though maybe yeah you
know you could see that by episode if
you're really doing this to another
level you could that's true you probably
could find that I'm wondering how do you
know that well because I catfish people
what was the goal for the cafe like was
it was it to make money I'll tell you so
at one point he tells he tells this girl
that uh hey
um I don't have any money because me and
Liv have a joint account and she doesn't
let me buy things yeah and she if she
checks always the money she checks my
statements
so you buy me some Bitcoin so this girl
ends up sending the fake DACA Montgomery
ten thousand dollars no
what what has this woman ever met her
met him like in person no of course not
what about FaceTime nothing bro I'm
telling you catfishing is a powerful
tool dude if you take my master class
you guys
he knows there should be a how to
catfish master class I mean there's
enough material out there there's a show
called Catfish bro how do you not know
that you see the patterns bro you can
see it but the reason is blind y'all so
desperate for connections but but she's
also married crazy
I know and she did divorce her husband
that's just [__] up though like
getting her to leave her husband well
how how old deserve it at this point uh
how old was the catfisher I don't think
did they catch the captain they never
found out who was the guy it was
probably some dude in Eastern Europe or
something bro when you sell somebody a
dream though like it's hard for them to
[__] pull themselves out and they
really but if you're willing to leave
your spouse for it then you deserve to
be sold yeah no for sure for sure well
maybe your husband was a piece of [__]
we don't know dude hot take a lot of the
people that are being catfished and
scammed it's because they want to
believe it yeah they really want to be
in there they want to there's probably
really friends and family telling them
like yo this is [__] stupid you don't
know I'm like I do you don't know you're
stupid dude that is honestly what she
said she said that like
um every day that she wakes up to
another message it's like it's because
they want dopamine hit and yeah she's
continuing yeah totally dude These Guys
these catfishing guys they're so good at
leaving that like breadcrumb Trail to
love you know I fall for it I'd fall for
it also like you know it's all it's like
a little bit come on let's have a little
empathy for this one
it can happen to anybody and on the one
hand you like feel bad for like the
husband she left on the other hand it's
like good riddance you know what I mean
yeah you can support me anyway I fall
for it knowing that it's a catfish
because I want I like I like the
interaction
I just want to talk he asks for 10 and
Joe sends him 20. you guys ever never
been in a situation like this at all
right catfished or was Cafe either way
either way I don't know why you're
bringing that up check his master class
dude and I've never been [__]
catfished ever man dude there's a
there's a friend of mine uh he's like in
the dance world he gets made fun of all
the time because he has the worst
catfish situation right now he does he
keep getting catfish no he got he got
massively catfished one time oh but um
he thought he was chatting with this
girl I think like they just met online
and stuff they're talking for a really
long time and they're like in Love or
Whatever never did like a FaceTime or
anything like that this is also before
FaceTime this is maybe like 15 years ago
yeah Skype right yeah there's no excuse
still but then uh so he eventually yeah
I think uh so he has to drive like a
good amount of time over to meet her at
her house he drives gets to the house he
got flowers like stereotypes flowers in
his hand knocks on the door so a guy
named Charlie comes in
and then this is what this is is what he
sees okay
[Music]
I'm sorry I lied for real [__] up no way
not even kidding I didn't do anything oh
was she like a smoker and she quit and
she has a voice box I think it was a
dude no it wasn't a dude it was a girl
but she was disabled in like a
wheelchair and it had like a like a
Stephen Hawking style she had a talk box
what did she send was it like her
picture but like she was she was lonely
so she sent someone else's picture yeah
someone else's pictures she simulated
entirely so he [__] held it down huh
he was like I don't care and then he
[__] busted that [__] he actually
hung out with her
he [__] her dude
he said
I don't care
I'm sorry I lied [__] it but low-key
that's that's the best case no he
actually
wanted to be your friend and like hung
out with her yeah that's a sweetheart
because like he understood that like oh
you just wanted the human connection
yeah and it's like difficult to get it
would have been way cooler if he yelled
at her a bunch called her a bunch of
names knocked her chair over it yeah
that would have been way cooler people
are they still friends to this day no I
don't think so
what was the point uh so wait they met
in person yeah right so
what was the point of her
bringing him getting him to come to I
think people are hopeful they're like
maybe they like me for who I am it's not
about the looks why didn't she want her
like but also too it might be like a
guilt thing it might just be like [__] I
just gotta I can't do this you're
betting on that the connection is
stronger than that's true yeah I guess
or in that situation that catfish that
catfish wasn't so much I'm gonna scam
this person for their money it was uh
I'm going to lie in hopes of something
greater too I think that is the end goal
right for a lot a lot of the time I
don't know if they're looking that far
either I think it's like a thing where
it just go goes out of proportion and
before they know it it's like yeah all
the lies I think I've never had like
money catfish because those are really
easy to find out but I I think it's like
sometimes they're not that easy jokes
profile catfish for like intimacy yeah
so that's that's I would consider that
one fake like catfish for intimacy it's
like it's heartbreaking at the same time
so it's like you could have yeah because
as though I think when people do that
they don't like themselves like they
don't they're not confident with what
they look like yeah because I think
um the two examples that I caught it was
one was uh like a like a gay boy that
was in the closet that wanted attention
right and then another one was a girl
but she was uncomfortable with who she
what she would look like oh all right
yeah yeah so I think like they'll have
like a hot girl or whatever that they
think you know a lot of people would
like and then they'll use those as a
you know what I could kind of look like
like I kind of look like them so they
justify like I kind of look like that so
it's okay oh my God that's the
justification yeah what do you think
Anthony's fake profile is thinking
my fake oh yeah when I'm when I'm
catfishing people you have a fake
profile no the one thing Ryan that's
being you oh the one that's messaging
you and the one that you keep on saying
he has this fake profile that every day
I I have an alarm to tell him to shut
the [__] up
I just keep saying shut up shut up you
suck every day and he's always like you
suck you shut up
[Music]
thank you